hello folks welcome to rational science
the only sight on the end there's honey
on the internet that does physics
rationally
everybody else moves Concepts around
and that distinguishes them from us
we call these people
Flatlanders or just plain idiots okay
what is an idiot
idiot is a person who uh has big Ideas
comes from the Klingon
idea you know everybody has normal ideas
and these people have idiots
so they have big ideas
and we have all kinds of people we have
Timmy diale you know he believes that
time dilates
and plays around with time uh we have
flux ether and he moves The Ether around
all these Concepts dance dance Danny uh
Flat Earth are there representative from
uh the electric Universe Eddie
Thunderbolts and so on so we have all
these people and they have big Ideas
okay and that's they have different way
of thinking than we do for sure and yeah
what we have is really a paradigm shift
here you know and this is uh with the
idiot typical idiot believes in typical
it moves Concepts such as field and
waves plasma electricity they move the
electricity even though electricity is
the movement according to them according
to the definitions electricity is the
movement of some kind of particle
and so they moved the movement of
particles that's essentially what
electricity is uh flat earthers they
move the density they say density is the
one that causes things to move downwards
gravity
black hole Dark Matter singularity
all these things move all these Concepts
move they move the function the wave
functions some call it they move energy
mass time the whole works okay they also
uh typically like to run experiments
and no we do not run experiments in
science
let me say that again in case you say it
was a slip of the tongue we do not run
experiments in science in science what
we do is we explain
results of the experiments okay you can
run all the experiments you want in your
dark basement when you come to the
conference you need to explain how it
happened what was the mechanism okay
that's what science is but running
experiments anybody can run in
experiments and not understand anything
a flat earther or a flat Lander or idiot
also attempts to prove theories okay
they're in to proof in fact and uh truth
they use those words and they introduce
belief which is another synonym of
knowledge
and opinion they introduce these
um
subjective uh things into science okay
so uh yeah they differ a little bit from
us we do not do anything like that here
in this site and that distinguishes us
from everybody else on the planet
okay so if you happen to come to this
site well you'll find a little bit of
um a paradigm shift here we have a
different way of looking at science okay
and it might scare you off because you
were probably educated in a different
way in high school or college and so
just be aware that this site has a
different version of science proposes a
different version of Science
and uh therefore of physics right it's
got nothing to do with math it's got
nothing to do with experiments it has to
do with explanations you need to explain
a mechanism in physics if you want to be
a physicist otherwise you are a
mathematician we call mathematicians
okay
anyways
um I turned 70 yesterday
seven decades okay
you might say well um
what uh how do you define 70 well what
is 70 you know and I can only say um
a way of concisely stating it is uh hair
starts to grow where it's not supposed
to
that's essentially what 70 is and yeah
uh hopefully you don't make it to 70
because uh you know or even later you
know because it you have all kinds of
problems uh in my case I get arthritis
can't even move my fingers anymore
almost you know can't play guitar used
to play uh better but uh now the fingers
are molasses they move a lot slower and
other people have other problems so uh
if you're in your 20s don't look forward
to it there's no future in aging okay
okay now the question is will I live
and here we're going to talk a little
bit about Extinction
and the question is you know I'm 70 will
I live another 10 years will I live
another decade
and there's two possibilities one that I
at least in in that context right one is
that
I won't make it to 80 because I died
earlier for whatever reason and another
one is that maybe the global
economy collapses as we propose here and
we have the extinction of man and I'm
included within that species in other
words which will come first my uh
regular death the one that maybe Mother
Nature scheduled for me you know because
my bones uh don't make it to the age of
80 or will it be the collapse of the
global economy that's the issue okay and
for this I'm gonna start by invoking a
gentleman who was my hero a long time
ago about 40 years ago to be
pretty correct about it his name was
Carl Sagan
okay and I was a admire Carl Sagan
primarily because he had good teaching
techniques okay he he was a guy who
talked calmly and so on and that's
something my Envy in him you know I'm a
hot head
I use words like idiots which I invented
you know and they're not into dictionary
so don't look them up and uh yeah he
probably wouldn't use that in public
speaking right he was a little more
gentleman-like than I am
okay so uh Carl Sagan he was my one of
my heroes right and uh but I stopped
having him as a hero because even though
he was a great teacher and I think all
of you who knew him or heard him or son
will agree with me that he he talked you
know call me and got his points across
uh why did I stop being a an admirer and
now I'm even embarrassed that I was an
admirer of his uh because he taught
nonsense everything that came out of his
mouth was absolute bunk nonsense
poppycock
everything okay and here let me uh just
point out a couple issues okay he became
uh essentially a caricature of science
as far as I'm concerned
okay and he vouched for quantum
mechanics general relativity and
strength Theory all three of which are
bunk nonsense the explanations given in
these three religions they're not even
religions I don't know what they what
they call them their irrationalities
they're all irrational all the
explanations given by these people are
irrational and they don't even uh
they're not even embarrassed by it they
think that humans are not supposed to
understand how the universe works that
our minds are a little different than
father universes so we don't think like
he does so we can't understand him he
doesn't understand us and that's okay
because we're just Petty humans
etc etc etc some people believe out
there some of these idiots that humans
will never discover how this universe
works it's just too Grand too infinite
too big
and we're so puny our minds cannot
comprehend it all
this is what these people have been
taught or this is what they've been led
to believe
that's what they believe in okay and uh
I think uh Sagan was somewhere in there
I can't say that he was really in there
but he did vouch for quantum mechanics
general relativity especially those two
mathematical physics in general and all
the explanations here are monk you
looked at his series Cosmos
it's a
synthesis of these of mathematical
physics essentially okay
uh and yeah mathematical physics is
total bunk nonsense
okay we don't care about the equations
we want to know the explanations of how
the universe works and in the end they
always say well that's philosophy
anyways ontology metaphysics whatever
they call it they dismiss it and so like
I wrote a paper the other day in Cora uh
why did they even attempt to explain
um
you know how this universe works why did
they try to give an explanation a
physical interpretation to their
equations if they're at the end going to
say well by the way because when you
challenge them you say well hold it you
said some nonsense there yes and all
that is philosophy anyways it's not part
of physics not part of science
so you know if you want to know how a
magnet attracts another they say well
that's philosophy
yeah just like you heard it they say
that's not part of physics that's not
part of science because we'll never know
and uh and you know the mind of uh
father universe is very different than
ours we don't comprehend his ways and
blah blah blah all they want is
measurement and equations they call that
science descriptions
uh the other thing I objected to Carl
Sagan eventually because I was there as
well he was an atheist and I used to be
an atheist and have I become a Christian
or a Muslim or a Buddhist uh no I became
a scientist in a science scientist
rejects atheism theism and agnosticism
all three of which are religion okay why
because they introduced the word belief
into their discussion into their debates
so uh you know a theist might say I
believe in the existence of God and the
atheist might say
um I don't believe in the existence of
God
and I don't think there is a God you
know anyway they want to say it I I
prove and I know for a fact that God
does not exist and uh agnostic might say
well I don't know if God exists I
haven't made up my mind I don't know
what test we could run to prove the
existence of God
all these three
uh
lines of thought are irrational
all we had to do all these years was
Define the word exist of course you got
to define the word God but more more
basic yet is the word exist
what does exist mean and no one in the
last three thousand years defined a word
exists and so they've been running
around in circles saying well God exists
no God doesn't exist well what did you
mean by exist oh we don't know but God
exists
so this was the problem
but uh then uh the other issue is that
Carl Sagan was involved with seti and
this is the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence in fact he was one of the
guys who sent a little thingy out there
with the one of the pros to see if maybe
the Martians somewhere somewhere in in
the universe could get a hold of it and
know that we're here you know where they
try to give him directions to our planet
so he believed that you know not only
were there people out there which is
very likely right People Like Us
intelligent beings right but not only
that there are beings out there but uh
that maybe maybe we have a chance of
contacting them
and for this you know you have this
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
and they listen in to see if they can
hear or you know somehow pick up uh
waves coming from another planet
okay some signal that someone sends us
you know the bottle in the ocean kind of
thing
okay and um
in in that regard uh again I think he
wasted his time I don't think there's
any chance whatsoever that we will ever
hear of another civilization
the good part about that which is uh the
one I will credit Sagan with and I'll
still stand behind him on that is that
he made a little comment he said
can you imagine if uh we were to contact
another civilization we may finally
finally made contact with another
civilization
you imagine that someone talking to us
from another planet somehow you know
that we communicate and we try to figure
out their language and Etc and we
eventually end up talking somehow even
though they're far away
and this would be interesting for one
thing that Carl Sagan mentioned and that
was that it kind of would unite the
world
okay so you have today you have three
Empires you know and these are uh
uh the three inputs that we have today
we have the um uh Russians we have the
Chinese and we have the Americans and
they have each uh either strong military
or strong economics you know and so
they are the ones who essentially govern
the planet we have three Empires today
and yeah they look more or less like
this yeah here we have the three Empires
okay Russia United States and China
and right now you know these three
groups essentially uh don't trust each
other you know and they might even go to
war further on
and what if if uh Mr Sagan was correct
and instead of competing and fighting
you know they work together
and they would work together uh maybe
because you know we contacted another
civilization like Carl Sagan says I
don't think that will ever happen but
what if there were other reasons what if
we realized that we're the last humans
on Earth
and the heads of state
kind of came down and said Okay hold it
you know uh if we're the last humans on
Earth
maybe uh if we worked together we might
able to maybe not avoid Extinction which
I think is impossible to avoid it but
maybe work together to prolong our stay
on the planet what things could they do
okay so this is this what I have in mind
okay is there anything that governments
can do
and let's see if I can give you a uh a
hint of what they might be able to do
here it is okay
uh let me make this smaller here
you know it's so big give me a second
here
there we go
and um
these are three things that maybe
governments could do if they were
together okay we're not talking about
the rich here we're talking about
implementing some kind of policy that
would prolong the lives of humans I'm
suggesting that we should not have any
more babies
tell women hey we recommend that you
have no more babies you say Bill that
goes against your your theory doesn't it
I mean we need more consumers right
well right now we're producing consumers
for services that's all we're doing
we're creating more and more services
and not producing any real stuff in
other words the real stuff the tangible
stuff is becoming a smaller and smaller
percentage of global economics what is
growing your services and within
services not the Hands-On services like
you know barbering and Landscaping and
stuff like that you know what's growing
now is uh internet services everybody
just opens up a YouTube channel or
whatever Channel Instagram
and uh they try to make a buck you know
getting ads
uh primarily you know and so it's uh and
what are these Services they are all um
entertainment they're geared towards
entertainment
we're running the world on entertainment
is that why we want to bring new
generations of children into the world
so that we have a world they live on a
world of entertainment
no we cannot run the world on
entertainment we are headed to
Extinction and all I'm saying is let's
prolong it and therefore we have to make
some drastic decision one uh decisions
one of which is let's stop having babies
so that those who are alive today can
live off their lives lives as far as
that we can
and we will not have a new generation of
babies to grow up and to Simply become
extinct very very early in life that
would be more of a tragedy in my opinion
than uh not having them to begin with
that's one suggestion okay I know you'll
kill me or ring my neck for that no
problem I'm just giving you my opinion
of what would prolong okay the our
species uh from dying sooner that's
that's the issue and I found new cities
you know
um
I just came from Argentina and that's my
country and uh it's a big country it's
an empty country it's only got 45
million people it's got so the eighth
biggest country in the world
and the whole South Patagonia is empty
land what if we could take some of the
people from the cities and found new
cities out the existing people right not
create new ones but just move them from
the cities with some kind of incentive
so that they go to the middle of nowhere
give them land
and instead of you know producing
Services
Goods would be okay but not services but
instead of that you know I haven't
produced agriculture or you know cattle
ranching or whatever Canada empty
country Australia empty country
Russia empty country
we have lots of empty land on the planet
and our population is really declining
but right now not only is the population
declining well we have declining of
something else we have first we have uh
the decline of manufacturing okay this
is global and you can see uh
manufacturing is going down the rate at
which we're producing tangible stuff is
going down
we say well we're services are becoming
a bigger percentage of the global
economy but it turns out that services
are also going down at least they were
until 2020 and
um
I think that the whole global economy is
gradually coming to a grind you know
that's a to a
friction you know there's a lot of
Direction and they're coming to a stop
okay and part of it has to do with the
fact that we're not producing children
and I've shown that before here it is
one more time uh population growth rates
are scheduled to go down they have been
going down since 1963 the last time we
had the highest level which was about
2.3 global population growth rate right
and now we're down to one I think we're
below one right now in the year 2020
2022 thereabouts and by mid-century it's
supposed to be somewhere in mid-century
we're supposed to reach zero population
growth
okay
and that's bad because it means there
will be no demand in the future
and that means it's going to take us to
a point where a lot of companies will
fold
and that's my
uh that's what I predict will happen uh
to the global economy I don't think we
can avoid it
and so what I'm suggesting really is
that we have stop it today if if I were
the dictator on Earth uh I would
recommend not dictate but recommend that
people stop having babies produce uh
agriculture in new cities New Towns you
know like in the old west so to speak if
we could manage that of course I'm
Dreaming out loud I'm convinced that
cannot happen I'm just saying that it
would be nice for it to happen because
that might change uh the length of time
humans live on the planet that's all I'm
suggesting
there's a book I read some time ago it's
known as grow or die it applies to any
economic system whether it's company
country or the world okay you have to
grow
or you die and right now we're on the
path of death because everything is
coming down Services manufacturing the
growth rate of the economic growth rate
as well as the population growth rate
both are coming down the rates are
becoming you know smaller and smaller
and smaller and this file says the
following says Dr land's theory of
transformation a Cornerstone in the
strategic planning and organizational
transformation of Corporations
but he says at the root of the principle
lies a single concept growth you have to
have growth the most basic and Universal
of drives through which all biological
physical chemical psychological and
cultural processes are intrinsically
equivalent
you have to have growth
you don't have growth you die
okay
so all I can say is we're not growing
right now so I think we're on the path
for extinction okay
um
someone might say well uh how soon will
that happen
okay and uh here it is
uh this is what uh
I've
suggest uh the picture or economic
picture looks like throughout the ages
let's assume we were born as a species
anywhere from 200 300 000 years ago okay
whatever it doesn't matter really but we
lived a long time very long time as
hunter gatherers okay primarily hunting
uh you can say at least 100 or 200 000
years we were hunter-gatherers even
before then but then about 10 000 years
ago or thereabouts uh we went into
farming agriculture
200 years ago we went into the
industrialization uh phase manufacturing
people moved from the country to the
cities the cities grew they produced
machinery for the country and the
country was able to become more and more
efficient without uh so many farmers
working in the land
that about uh maybe I'd say more like 40
years now about 1980 Services took over
and he started uh
becoming a bigger percentage of the um
of the GDP in advanced Nations
and today uh we've gone even beyond that
because now we have certain not only
services are maybe around 85 percent of
some of these countries GDP and
Workforce but uh a lot of that is now
being shifted to a new kind of service
which is
um internet services
and so uh my take on that is that
services are another is another word for
unemployment
okay service is uh a uh an abstract
production of whatever of nothing of
abstractions you're not producing
anything
uh all we're doing is trading with each
other
you know I scratch your back you scratch
someone else's bag and that guy
scratches the third guy's back all we're
doing is scratching each other's backs
and I'm not sure
the few who produce good especially food
uh you know as long as you know how long
can we continue just doing Services you
know waving my hand and I get food
somewhere from somewhere from God
someone gives it to me someone produces
it and brings it to me
uh how long can we continue with this uh
for the next million years
okay and so I'm saying that that cannot
be sustained it's impossible
okay and of course uh some people object
to my theory saying uh Bill you're crazy
okay
I'll accept that as a as a an objection
uh primarily I say the people who object
to it are the um
micro economists
they don't care about macro stuff I'm a
macro Economist by nature but all these
people are micro economists they they
want to know how to make money
themselves how to how they can get into
Bitcoin or trade with your uh neighbor
without having the government intervene
in their Affairs like you know through
taxation or anything like that they want
freedom from government
and uh so they don't realize that macro
trumps uh micro every day
macro is the big one is the strategy
micro is the uh tactics you could say
and
um
no I think macro Trump's micro so the
majority of people who object are what I
call Narco uh capitalist and Narco
capitalist narcocaps they're the new
communists
really anarchists you know they don't
want government but not in the sense of
you know 19th century where they threw
bombs the yanakis uh did their own
politics individual politics they threw
bombs now these people are not like that
at least not all of them or most of them
now they just want the government off
their backs and they think that as long
as you can take government off your back
uh you know I I can get along with my
neighbor and trade with him and so on
they think they can run the world like
this everybody just taking care of
themselves without a government
uh what can I say
uh no
okay so these are the people I think
that object to a lot of my theories and
no problem we all have different
opinions about how uh or theories of how
this world is run and how it should be
run and that kind of thing okay and I'm
again my concentration is on extinction
and not on politics or specifically
economics only as they relate to
Extinction and so it windfall says the
following says how do you think modern
society can even exist without money
today
yeah you got it you understood it
yeah modern society cannot live without
money today
okay so you said it right you just it
probably didn't understand what you said
okay that's the point the point is that
if money goes out we can't not run the
world
so we had better uh trust in God like
the dollar bill says because the day we
lose our faith in money
we're all dead
okay so we have this abstraction that
keeps us all alive okay and this
abstraction is simply oh I want money I
want gold I want crypto I want whatever
you know dollar bills give it to me and
I'll take it why because I can unload it
to someone else
or I know or I believe that I can unload
it to someone else tomorrow that's why I
want it that's why you might crave it
right
question is what happens the day that
you cannot unload it because you don't
want it
or no one wants it
when money is no more because we all
lost faith and money
I mean we're in we have inflation eating
money every day
and I always give the example if I gave
you you you're selling your hat
and I said how much you want for it and
you say I'll take ten dollars
okay I'll give you ten dollars in
Vietnamese money
will you take it
might say well no I don't want
Vietnamese money I can't do anything
with it
well I thought money was money was money
I mean yeah it's guaranteed by the
Vietnamese government why don't you want
it
well because money is not money is not
money and some money we don't want okay
sure you don't want Argentine pays
they're devalued
and fellow says the world's Filthy Rich
capitalists will always find a way of to
keep it running and no they can't do
anything about it Extinction has uh is
you know it's something it's unavoidable
it's in the cards it was in the cards
since from the moment Mother Nature Made
Us made our species
whenever that was 200 300 000 years ago
it was already into cars our
intelligence would take us to develop
all these uh different uh systems uh
money you know first it was bartering
then we went to gold or or
um coins of different silver and so on
then we went to some kind of paper money
ious and so on then we moved into what
crypto today and so on WE and people
think it's a question of you know
replacing green money with brown money
no this is not an issue of money it's
the the issue here is that you cannot
continue giving people
uh bonuses and uh freebies
to so that they can reach the end of the
month and when people are out of work
either they break windows and burn tires
or you give them money and keep them
happy
and so the governments are now creating
money lots of places on the planet and
just giving it to people so that they
don't go out into the streets
and the fewer the less work there is the
more unemployment or the less employment
there is and the more the government has
to fill in that hole by creating money
and that's what's happening across
almost every country on the planet right
now just pick your country and you'll
find the same thing you're just creating
money and giving it to people and I'm
not sure that you can do that the fewer
and fewer workers maintain ever greater
and greater people who live off the
system Off the Grid
that's got a crash at some point
at least that's my theory uh saying that
we cannot avoid it okay and someone says
a global economic collapse isn't what
happened to the dinosaurs
absolutely yes that's that is what
happened
all animals have economics they all
manage one's resource specifically and
that is food I don't know any animal
that does not manage food and that's
what economics is it's a management of
resources
okay so all animals manage food and
carnivores manage the herbivores and the
herbivores manage whatever's on the
floor you know green plants and what
happens is that the green plants
disappear the ones that the herbivores
ate and uh that takes care of the
herbivores which
uh indirectly takes care of the
carnivores
that's what happens in in a mass
extinction plants disappear why because
they went through their cycle their
millions of years cycle and at some
point they gotta go
well you gotta go you gotta go
uh humans are omnivores has nothing to
do with it uh humans can process pretty
much anything into food again nothing to
do with the theory this is not an issue
of whether we can eat anything that's
out there this is an issue of when not
if but when the global economy collapses
when money is no more
trade is no more there is no Commerce
everyone's on his own
when everyone is on his own
people will be killing each other but
I'm getting ahead of myself because
here's another fellow who says the
following he says uh
says just get some ranch and you have a
salad you know plant something the guy
thinks he's going to be living you know
in California with some kind of land
there and says oh you know I'll just
plant my own food and have my own cows
and my pigs and I'll live on the farm
just like you know the old-fashioned way
no no
uh when the global economy collapses
you'll be a farmer by day and a soldier
by night like in the Hop lights you know
uh Greek hoplites uh the guy um
what was it in the winter they would go
and fight in the summer they would plant
that was more or less the general feel
in other words the farmer was a was a
fighter also was a gladiator on the
field uh yeah he was needed in the Army
and of course A lot of them were slaves
but you know everybody did agriculture
in those days and now if you if when do
when the global economy collapses you're
going to have to defend your land
because other people will not be
planning they'll be stealing and killing
and murdering and cannibalizing
okay they'll be eating you
so you're gonna have to defend your land
against thousands of people from the
cities who know nothing about planning
so you say well I'm just going to retire
you know good Mar-A-Lago kind of thing
you know your own Plantation your own uh
Farm
think again
you're going to be fighting 99 of the
time and whether you have any time to
plant and to harvest
uh I don't know uh that's that's up in
the air you will be fighting for your
land you'll be fighting for your life
and more than likely you'll be stealing
and killing just like everybody else so
no this notion that you're gonna have
your own salad your own lettuce tomato
I don't think so
okay and uh final common person said it
says um uh Martin Armstrong said this in
2014.
well I looked this follow-up I didn't
know him uh and uh no all I can tell you
is uh this Armstrong oh he talked about
his Cycles
you know he said there are cycles and he
just put a number to it like he says
like it's 8.4 or 8.6 years and things
repeat themselves
nothing yeah he didn't say anything
about Extinction for sure and he just
talked about cycles and I'm saying the
Cycles end someday the last cycle is the
winner takes us into Extinction
okay not because I'm pessimistic but
because I'm realistic
okay
okay uh let's get on with the subject
matter of today and that is the graviton
okay
what is the graviton
here uh let's see if I can get it
um
uh I'll start with this or favorite most
humans are math magicians
I'd say at least 95 of humans on Earth
are mathematicians and only about five
percent are physicists
they think in physical terms they are
rational people the majority of people
think in terms of spirits
and those people who in the past used to
think in terms of spirits ghosts gods
angels you know that sort of thing they
moved into something new which is you
know Concepts abstract Concepts they
believe in fields in mass in energy and
they move these things around thinking
their things
and that that makes a difference which
is uh what I was talking about earlier
when I started today the introduction
okay and here it is more or less 95 of
humanity they're math magicians uh
traditional mathematicians uh they work
with Spirits Angels Gods you know the
modern mathem magicians they move
Concepts around they think Concepts
cause
things to happen and so all the physical
interpretations
are mediated by abstract mathematical
Concepts on the other hand five percent
of humanity are physicists and um this
is this are people who believe or who
have the sense or theorize that
um
Mother Nature does not work with
Concepts or with spirits
that there are objects there that we
cannot see or touch
and an object that we cannot see or
touch is not the same thing as a concept
object that we cannot see or touch is
not the same as a spirit or our God okay
so uh mathematicians essentially Believe
In Black Magic whereas the physicists
think
that mother nature is simply messing
around with us she's fooling us she's
making doing a magic trick
she's not showing you what's in that
invisible world of hers that's all that
there is but there better be something
in there okay we would like to think
that mother nature looks something like
this okay
cute little girl okay
that's nice naive you know this is
mother name she loves us
okay
math magicians have a different version
they uh think that mother nature does
black magic she's a mean old witch
okay uh so uh I don't know you might
want to consider which side you're on do
you believe that mother nature uh is
fooling us
you know or does she actually do black
magic and here let me give you an
example okay here it is yeah you go to
the uh to the show and there's a
magician on stage
and you see this okay
guy moves his magic wand
and he makes a rabbit disappear
okay or up here I'm sorry there he is
disappear moves it around
hey wander around
and the rabbit appears
okay simple okay
a lot of you saw tricks similar to these
to this one right and
um
so yes the mathematician next to you
how did he do that
and the guy says well he made it appear
from the void
they actually believed that you know the
rabbit was made from nothing
you have the quantum mechanics uh
mechanic
Mechanicals right and they believe or
they theorize right that particles come
in from the void
you have the general relativists and
they believe that the matter you know
the universe so to speak right in fact
space and matter right
uh began had a beginning
there was a start it came from nothing
which is what space is nothing but uh
they say space came from nothing too I
guess right because space is something
in their view so space the something
space as well as the something matter
both space and matter they came from
absolutely nothing
and they have no problem believing in
this in theorizing like this and they'll
tell you this in your face
and so yeah they believe that the rabbit
came out of nothing and they'll tell you
yeah and they have no problem believing
this they have no problem theorizing
like this
now you know it doesn't it doesn't they
don't lose any sleep over this
and so yeah it kind of worries you
because you say
um you know how can it possibly be that
these people went to college 10 years
and more they're professionals and they
actually theorize they propose the
physical interpretations include
the appearance of something out of
nothing matter out of space not even
space I can't even say space because
even space came out of space or better
yet to say spaces are something that
came out of nothing whatever nothing is
because they never defined nothing they
never defined space they just say it's
in finance made out of particles and
there's energy in there and blah blah
blah you know they fix the problem that
way
okay uh but this is what they believe
that's what a math magician believes and
95 percent of humanity are mathem
magicians and only about five percent
are
uh rational humans we call them
physicists
okay and last week uh I talked about
this the fact that you have the Higgs
what is the Higgs well you can think of
it as a bunch of fish going through the
ocean
and
um the Higgs is a particle of mass that
goes through a field known as the Higgs
field the ocean in this case right and
some fish move easier through this ocean
and some fish take you know or have a
hard time getting through there those
that have a hard time they weigh a lot
okay and um those are thin I guess or
have less volume or whatever you know
way less
uh you know they they move easier
through the river or through the ocean
and because of that they
um they have less Mass this is the
notion they have so mass is a question
of interaction according to the Higgs
version right and you could say that the
Higgs is the opposite of the graviton
because whereas the graviton causes
gravity the Higgs kind of uh opposes
gravity you know it it has this inertia
it it scrapes its shoulder or its elbow
against uh this ocean right
and so we have on the one hand you have
the gravitons I guess you could say the
field of gravitons the particles that
form this ocean
and and you have the fish moving against
the ocean and it Crea it interacts
within because of that interaction we
have the particle of mass and the
particle of gravity the graviton
I guess that's the best way I can put it
because they never really visualize it
it's all math
and we're trying to visualize it because
we're trying to figure out how this
universe works how does gravity work
especially at the quantum level
okay so that's what we're trying to
explain here we're trying to visualize
it we're trying to imagine what these
people are talking about trying to make
a movie of it in our mind right
okay what's the problem with that well
with the uh so-called Higgs well it's a
particle of mass but mass is defined as
the quantity of matter or a measure of a
Quant of the quantity of matter
so we're talking about quantity of
matter we're talking about number of
particles uh we're talking about County
marbles
okay we're saying uh in this case uh we
have 12 marbles that's the mass of that
object that you see there it's a 12
marble
object
then we all understand you say Okay 12
marbles here if 20 over there 100 over
there we understand that
weight on the other hand is a
measurement it's not counting it's got
to do with measuring okay and what
you're measuring is a resistance of some
kind and interaction
so the particle of mass known as the
haze is actually a particle of weight
because it's defined the behaves is
defined as an interaction
of the pig's particle with the field
there's some kind of interaction there
and there's resistance there's some kind
of I guess friction
you know whatever you want to call it
and because of that uh the particle has
mass and that mass somehow is
transferred to other particles
uh if you can try to visualize that they
do it mathematically we don't care about
that we want to know how it works in
real life and of course they cannot
visualize that but my point here is that
the Higgs is like I said the other day
it's a particle of weight because it's
it has to do with interaction it doesn't
have to do with counting which is what
mass is defined as
okay and of course they had to Define
mass in different ways to to incorporate
weight into the definition of mass
that's what I'm saying mass and weight
are exactly the same until until the
mathematicians are able to
separate one from the other
and through through a definition first
of all right
and then uh yeah they determine mass by
weighing so right now we can't tell the
difference they say look if you take the
grand kilo Legrand kilo that used to be
the standard of mass in France right if
we take a grand all the way to the moon
it's going to weigh less
and we say the weight change but not the
mass
but the mass change because what we're
going to do on the moon is weigh it we
don't know how many atoms or
hydrogen atoms unit of mass uh the
granular head here on Earth and we don't
count them we just took and waited and
so yeah it weighs differently that means
that the mass also changed because we
determine mass by weighing so we haven't
learned much uh with uh the difference
between mass and weight
okay so here we have
um
a simple trick that I sometimes do here
you have a spoon okay and I'm gonna drop
it okay in fact I didn't drop it what I
did was just let go of it okay I didn't
push it downwards and then somehow it
falls to the ground it doesn't fall to
the ceiling
how do you do it with gravitons
which is the Quantum proposal
uh well you uh let go of it and it goes
down so you think that the only way that
can be done is something pushing it from
above
I don't think you could have particles
pulling it from Below how do you pull
with particles
you know it's it's got to be a push
mechanism with particles
you know you can't it can't pull it
particles no matter how you'd say it now
you can have this Shadow effect like
lasage and so on no problem but it's
always going to be a push
of some kind
okay
so we're talking about push gravity when
you're talking about grab at times okay
and here it is more or less Illustrated
okay you have uh the green pixels as our
science critic uh suggested once you
have all these particles pushing the uh
spoon downwards we can all understand
that okay it's got a lot of problems
because you know you say why are the
particles directed downwards okay why
aren't they upwards why aren't they
sideways you know what happens to those
particles but we can understand the
mechanism someone says look the the
spoon came down because particles pushed
it down okay we understand the mechanism
no problem whatsoever the problem now is
that that's the quantum version
assuming you know there are other
versions but I'm just going with one of
them which is graviton's pushing it
downwards okay
um here's the general relativity version
which is does that include particles
which does not include force in fact
okay here's the uh general relativity
version okay you have a spoon and it
just is pulled down I guess because the
canvas the space-time canvas so-called
four-dimensional space-time canvas goes
downwards okay so either it it creates a
hole and the spoon just Falls in that
hole or the spoon itself is pushing it
down who knows but the point is this
would be something similar to this would
be what the general relativistic version
would be and so how do you reconcile
these two uh versions you have on the
one hand the particles pushing it down
and here you have the general relativity
pulling down where the canvas uh Falls
underneath the
feet of the of the spoon
you cannot reconcile the um these two
versions
so even if they get all the math
together and they figure out you know
how
gravity works in the quantum world and
they figure out the gravity uh the the
graviton what it is a bunch of particle
is pushing it down or you know
transferring negative momentum or any of
that
that mechanism is irregant syllable with
what we have in general relativity which
is the space-time canvas mechanism which
is why Einstein became a hero in 1919
when Mr uh Arthur Eddington proved that
Einstein's theory was correct
so we have these two mechanisms and
they're different they cannot be
reconciled and so we have a problem
because it means that even if these
people who are researching
in the case of general relativity and in
the case of quantum they're researching
gravity they're never going to put the
quantum World equal to the general
relativistic world
it cannot be reconciled okay and so what
happens here we have
uh the middle version the one that has
been growing maybe in the last 40 years
they're trying to get away from the
particle and they're trying to get away
from the canvas so to speak
and the way they get away from that is
they made ever more popular stronger the
theory of fields
okay so they're all all regions uh not
only the general relativists and the
quantum mechanics but also the strength
here is they're all working with fields
why because the field is a very
um
you could say accommodating uh entity
on the one hand they say the vibrate
local vibration of a field is a particle
but at the same time the field where is
a field will extends all the way to the
edges of space-time so you have the Best
of the Best of Both Worlds the field
represents two things the localized
vibration which is a particle a you know
point or whatever you want to call that
and also it extends all the way to the
edge of space-time
so it's got the discrete and the
extended all in one that's why they love
the field so the field you can hear all
these people these they talk about field
Quantum field Theory the general
relative it's a field Theory also so
everything is a field now
okay and so uh here's the vibration
local vibration of the field okay and I
showed it for
um the Higgs the other day I'm going to
show it also for the graviton because
there's no difference they're gonna
they're gonna say that L particles are
just by local vibrations of the field
and so there you have a graviton that's
what a graviton looks like you always
wanted to know there you have it that's
what a graviton looks like don't look
for it in the quantum in the standard
model of quantum mechanics
you won't find it there they don't have
the G for graviton that's why it's not
in the standard model but here you see
it in this place always illustrates
everything we Illustrated the graviton
for you that's what it looks like okay
and here's what a bunch of gravitons
look like okay more or less like that
you can see all the little you see the
field which is the whole thing the whole
shebang and then you also see the local
vibrations of each field or regions of
the field and
so we have both particle and we have
also extended field all in one shot okay
so this is what they love they love this
thing be this thing called field because
it gives them the best of both worlds on
the one hand they say look it's a local
vibration of the field you say oh that's
a particle and you go home happy because
they explain the particle to you
and you say well how about you know how
does this influence that over there well
see it's part of the field
it's part of the ocean extended ocean
and so this fish
which is simply actually a wave of the
ocean not a fish like a separate entity
it's it's a vibration of the ocean
itself which is a wave and this wave
affects that wave over there through the
ocean through other waves I guess
so wave effects wave through the waves
and what are the waves the waves that is
the motion of the ocean that's more or
less the notion of a field that's why
they love the word field
so let's uh look up the word field and
we find some problems here you know here
we find that field is a quantity is
represented by a number that has a value
for each point in space and time and
there you see what each one of those
words mean okay but essentially a field
is just a number that's it it's just
actually it's a bunch of numbers and
when they say that the field is
vibrating what they're saying is that
the numbers themselves are vibrating
that's what these people are actually
saying so we have a problem because
they're not talking physics they're
talking mathematics
and they don't even realize that anymore
because they've always thought of a
field as a region where something is
happening and they say there's a
something in there in the field whether
it's a magnetic field or a gravitational
field or electric field something is in
there
but it's that something which that
they've never identified
and so what they've done is they said
well we don't care what it is because a
mathematician doesn't care what's in
there he just says look we can measure
the strength of the field locally in
each one of those space and we say here
it's stronger and here it's weaker
that's all they care about and they say
here it's so many you know so many uh
whatever Newtons or whatever the if it's
a gravitational field they can tell you
what the strength of the field is at
different points in that region but they
cannot identify the invisible intangible
things that are causing that effect
okay and so one fellow says here he
sends me a note or a comment and he says
field is a mathematical representation
Regional differences in strength exactly
that's all it is it's a bunch of uh
abstractions well we're talking about a
bunch of numbers that are moving are
vibrating so yeah it is a mathematical
representation it's just Regional
differences in strength and that is not
a physical object where this fellow
mentioned here is a concept and we
cannot do physics with abstract Concepts
so for all those who try to do that they
are what what do we call them
Flatlanders that's what we call them
okay uh we had our
science critic
and he made a video criticizing the
scientific method incredible but he's
allowed to do that and uh
you know we're answering piece by piece
everything that
he mentioned because he essentially
addressed every topic so it was a good
um way of addressing you know uh
his objections making a video on each
one of his objections and in this case
he did the definition of life he is of
the opinion that the word life has been
defined by biologists and all I had to
do was look it up instead of making a
fool of myself
yeah okay uh sometimes I want to make a
fool of myself because I want to make a
point and the point is that no one has
ever defined a word life
with Biology the study of life or the so
they say means we don't have any
biologist on planet Earth because not
one of them can Define the word life in
a way that he can use it consistently
okay that's that's going to be my point
okay so uh this fellow just says the
following and listen carefully here it
goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
has anyone ever defined the word life
scientifically
and is a listing of actions most living
entities can do a scientific definition
of life
life is defined as any system capable of
Performing functions such as eating
metabolizing excreting breathing moving
growing reproducing and responding to
external stimuli maybe actually check to
see if anyone has defined the thing that
you're claiming that no one has defined
okay
um so he's got all these
things that he says living things do
and that's more or less what you'll find
out there
and biologists agree today that there is
no real definition of the word life
it's just a listing of properties that
they think that a living entity should
do but they cannot tell you what life is
they don't have a definition of the word
life therefore we don't have a
definition of the word biologist because
biology is supposedly the study of life
and so let's start with this with
definitions because
um you don't have a definition of the
word definition
these people don't know what a
scientific definition is
and so you look up and say well what is
a definition
you'll be we got to start somewhere and
that's a good place to start defining
what a definition is to begin with
a scientific definition we're talking
about here not just uh for an ordinary
speech but for science okay so what is a
definition well here you have all these
versions okay I got these three versions
from different places uh the one on the
left says there's like seven or eight uh
definitions of definition uh the one on
the right says there's five at least
types of definition the one on the
bottom uh says there's uh all
definitions attempt to explain or
clarify a term and they have at least
three definitions formal informal and
extended
so we have all these types of
definitions out there but again they
can't not Define what a definition is
what does the word definition mean what
is a definition
so you know we look it up and here we
have I think it's uh from the Wikipedia
let's see it uh
no this is my version sorry we don't
have a definition of the word definition
you can look it up yourself okay but
this is what we're saying that a
definition is a scientific definition a
limitation placed on the extent or usage
of a word
that's the definition of the word
definition okay
definition is not the same as meaning
okay definition is what a prosecutor
proposes meaning is what the juror gets
out of it okay meaning has to do with
how a definition is interpreted if a
definition is on the emitting end
meaning is on the receiving end a
prosecutor issues definitions a jur
inverse meaning
okay so that's our starting point and uh
here we have one father who tries to
Define life he did his best and he says
life may be a computer simulation
okay life's an illusion okay life is
just fantasy
okay those are the nurses got sometimes
I feel like I'm living a life of
Illusion
okay uh so yeah different people have
different Notions of what life is or
what a living entity is uh as well
thinks it's fantasy okay life is fantasy
that's uh unique definition here's
another these are the ones you'll find
on the internet I just put four of them
because there's so many definitions
you'll see that in here as if the person
says life is defined as any system
capable of Performing such functions and
you go through a list of functions uh
another one has more or less the same
thing seven characteristics another one
says all living organisms senior several
key characteristics or functions again
uh they just mentioned a bunch of things
that living entities do but I like the
last one says as many as 123 definitions
of Life have been compiled
loved it
we have 123 definitions of what life is
people have different Notions like this
fellow he thinks it's fantasy okay
uh illusion that's live life for him
that a living entity is one that has
Illusions I guess or lives in fantasy
I don't know okay so we don't know what
uh
uh life is here's the definition I think
from the Wikipedia okay
biology the scientific study of life
now in science we do not just study
anyone can study and not understand
anything
so studying should not be used as a
definition for anything any branch of
science the word study should be
eliminated we don't study in science in
studying we EX in in science we explain
anyone can study anyone can run
experiments anyone can do an equation
that doesn't mean they understand
anything okay
life a quality that distinguishes matter
that has what biological processes such
as signaling self-sustaining processes
from that which is not does not and is
defined by the capacity for growth
reaction to stimuli metabolism uh energy
transformation and reproduction
so um
if your grandmother
does not reproduce
she's not alive
if your aunt can't reproduce
she never lived she was never alive
do all entities reproduce
how about two uh homosexuals can they
reproduce are they alive
you know uh so you know all this is
nonsense because this does not apply to
every individual out there or to every
living entity okay not all entities
reproduce and if they don't I mean are
they supposed to reproduce every day and
if they don't reproduce the next day of
the
hen doesn't put an egg the next is is
not alive I mean what is this
no you cannot you cannot use the word
reproduction to Define life
okay because it's not Universal that's
why you cannot so we have a different
definition we say biology is rational
explanations related to living entities
what is a living entity what do we mean
by alive being alive right a natural
object that moves against the path of
least resistance primarily
gravity if you can move against gravity
of your own free will not like a rock
that is thrown Against Gravity but of
your own free will right that means that
uh it's a natural object has to be one
made by Mother Nature not one made by
humans we can make little toy planes fly
Against Gravity we can make little
robots that go up the mountain or pixels
on the screen those are not a lie
because we're talking about natural
entities that have the ability their own
personal ability you know to move
primarily Against Gravity that's a
living entity and a first entity to be
able to do that was the cell
okay whether plant or animal doesn't
matter because they all can move against
gravity they gravity says you moved this
way and the cell moves in the opposite
direction that's the point so life is
the set of living objects and biology
against D study I'm sorry the
explanations related to living entities
okay we have a definition and so now we
are able to
carry out a discussion but to say that
you know it's that which reproduces and
has children and if you don't have
children that means you are not alive
and if you never had children or you
never lived
I don't think that that'll work for
science okay
let's get to the questions comments
people made couple of them here one
fellow says the whole point of the
famous equation E equals MC squared is
that mass and energy are interchangeable
everything is energy ultimately
well the problem with that is that Mr uh
Richard fireman Matt I'm sure he
outranks you uh he got a noble okay he
said it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge of
what energy is so anyone using the word
energy is introducing spirits
so to say that everything is Spirit Well
we haven't said much
sorry uh yeah no go with energy energy
is a bad word to use just like field
more or less Mass all those were time we
don't use those words in science those
are four letter words as far as science
physics right is concerned uh fellow
says reality is merely an illusion of by
a uh very persistent one okay supposedly
said by Albert Einstein he also said
what we have called matter is energy
and what do we just say that energy we
don't know what it is okay whose
vibration has been so lowered as to be
perceptible to the senses there is no
matter
well if uh Albert Einstein girl aini
said that well you know why he stuck his
tongue out because he was out of his not
out of his brain out of his rocker
okay so yeah uh he was not a very
intelligent person okay all he did was
make an equation and then give it uh the
most irrational physical interpretation
he could find which is the bending of
the concept four-dimensional concept
called space-time which Stephen Hawking
says is unimaginable
yeah you cannot imagine any concept
you have to Define Concepts okay so
space time can be defined it cannot be
visualized it cannot be
grasped uh through images because it's a
concept we don't grasp Concepts through
images like love or intelligence
okay and here's uh now fellow says
existence question mark what do you mean
by existence pal answers him says exists
having objective reality
um poor word because reality is a
synonym of exist so that didn't work but
he had some very closest length width
and height having position location I
guess he got that from this site because
nobody defines an object as having
location being the definition of
existence we do in this side so he got
that here from here no problem uh you
should give credit what credit is due
but we don't say it's length within High
we say it's an object that has location
the problem he's got is that he puts uh
having position location he defines
location as position
so he goes around in circle obviously he
never defined never learned to define
words scientifically and that's why he
makes these basic errors now the way we
say it in science as we say exists is
physical presence okay what is physical
it's an object what is presence location
an object then has location by
definition exists that's the definition
of the word exist what is an object that
which has shape okay what is uh location
well first you define distance which is
the separation between objects and then
we say location in the universe right
what is the location of the earth well
it's the local set of distance that the
set of separations from every other from
every atom in the universe
that's the location of the earth there's
no math involved no number lines
no measurement none of that if you just
say what is the location physical
location well it's a set of distances to
every atom every object in the universe
that's the location of the Earth in the
universe
yeah we don't care how much
we just care where it is with respect to
everything else
okay and uh someone tells us final issue
says if the process of the ropes Fanning
out you know we talk about gravity being
the Fanning out of the electromagnetic
ropes that interconnect every atom in
the universe okay so one object falls or
rolls around another like the Earth
around the Sun why because the Run Sun
Twirls the Earth around from all these
electromagnetic roasts that bind every
atom on Earth to every atom of the sun
essentially this is the situation okay
this is why the Earth Twirls around the
Sun my hand is the sun and the ball is
the earth okay the Earth is bound
every atom on Earth is bound to every
atom of the Sun so the sun Turtles the
Earth around and that's why and and
space is nothing so the Earth cannot rub
its shoulder against space that's why
the earth goes around the Sun forever
and ever and ever not really forever uh
there are some
uh conditions there as well to consider
but the issue is the reason the earth
goes around the Sun is that the sun
Twirls the Earth around itself through
the countless electromagnetic
uh threat ropes right which are
intangible and invisible
ropes go right through ropes Mother
Nature does not have ropes touching
ropes and until you get that square in
your head you're going to have a lot of
trouble at least on this side anyways uh
he says
um
process of the Rose Fanning out makes
the ball fall then what causes that
process to start in the first place
well this is the answer the answer is
the universe is in
eternal
pinball machine now the pinball you know
you have the guy shooting the first ball
right and then it goes and hits and goes
around right but think of it as it's
just perpetual motion so you're talking
about what's the origin of motion that's
essentially what you're asking that's
ultimately what you're asking there is
no beginning to motion okay there is no
beginning to motion and so everything is
already moving in the universe right and
now we're just going to look at one case
of that to find out why that thing
approaches something else gravity
panning out and we're just saying you
know the asteroid approaches the Earth
or the moon or the sun whatever
and why is it Falling Towards the Earth
well because again the ropes are Fanning
out that's why that asteroid that
specific we're just going to chop that
the situation that predicament that
thing from the rest of the universe
we're gonna say why does that asteroid
fall to Earth that's all we want to
understand okay we're saying that the
ropes fan out
you say well what started the asteroid
from moving what gave what kick-started
it
and again everything in the universe is
moving nothing can stand still not even
God you know I want to move God since
every atom of God if God exists right
now what is existence uh means physical
presence means that God is Not only an
object okay but every one of his atoms
is bound to every one of the atoms in my
body
so all I have to do to move God is move
my finger I move my finger and God moves
with respect to my finger whether he
likes it or not so he can be all
powerful he can live in The Fifth
Dimension for all we care but I can move
God any time I can change the distance
of every atom in my hand to every atom
in his body if he exists right uh and
I'm moving God right now because every
atom in his body is moving with respect
to every atom in my finger everything in
the Universe moves was there a starting
point was there someone who kick-started
and put everything in motion
well that was known as God until he
stopped existing when God began to exist
well he couldn't get anything started
yeah God uh if you're going to put him
in there he's got to if if he wants to
exist God wants to be exists he's got to
be an object first and then he has to
have location which is the set of
distances with respect to every atom in
the universe if he doesn't have those
two conditions God does not exist by
definition not because I believe or to
stop believing in him you know
uh he wants to exist he just has to
follow the rules and the rule is you
know he's got to be an object and he's
got to have location
with that I'll see you next week next
Sunday we'll see you there bye bye